[Music]
welcome home honey
do you read now what is this it's
classified
oh I'm sorry
you weren't invited
they call it bad behavior
hey why are you here I got this
situation when I need your help I need
bad friends
cause I'm the new guy is that sniper
don't worry about it I got a
prescription oh guys remember this face
oh shoot it by accident
terrorists have taken possession of
nuclear missiles on a cargo ship off the
coast
if these babies go off
it'll be world war three
to choose this life over friends
over family
It's Time to Get Loud
next slide baby
[Music]
of imitation distance constitutes the
reservation
that's what I'm talking about
[Music]
is that the biggest one you've got oh
it's way bigger than that
this is Bella
Bella this is Mr McCandless hello fella
no
she's an experiment good evening and
rainy and her body are not quite
synchronized
but she's progressing at an accelerated
piece
[Music]
tell me where did she come from
or it is a happy tail
[Music]
I am Bella Baxter and there is a world
to enjoy so I can navigate it is the
goal of all to progress grow a woman
plotting her course to Freedom
[Music]
foreign
boys where have you been
we're just running errands that's it
oh sorry Splinter some of the guys
wanted to get pizza and I tried to talk
him out of it yeah you ratted us out
don't use that word that way I mean it's
20 25 already dead
monsters that were shunned by society
and we could do what we wanted
[Music]
what would you guys do go to high school
maybe get a girlfriend can you imagine
that not likely
[Music]
I want to know everything about you our
dad is definitely not a giant rat that
makes me feel like he's a rat
police are baffled by the recent crime
wave led by a Superfly nobody's ever
seen his face why because he kills
everyone who does
no not cool a bit cool we pick out super
fun and then everyone will think we're
cool they'll accept us
he's making a deal tonight under the
Brooklyn Bridge
I can't believe there are other mutants
you want to roll with us
humans are never gonna like us
so we gonna let the mutants rule the
Earth
people's they got to go okay um sort of
a twist
stop him we gotta try
six in the morning police at my dog
my son Michelangelo you have heart
Donatello you have wisdom Rafael you
have bravery and Leonardo honored
I've talked I dream about fighting every
night you've got a rage it's not a
problem
could the ugly untalented gays please
report to the principal's office yes
that's you guys
tonight is our night we're heading the
couch I'm gonna talk to Brittany you get
that Isabelle what would I say hey girl
how's your boyfriend how's his penis
spell you both for committing a crime
against Jeff get out of the car
[Music]
we were just cracked cracking for a
self-defense club like a Fight Club yes
just stay in your lane into your
munching Beaver Wesleyan yes sir
what's your plan here Jeff is like
caught it and they're picking on the
weak and defenseless so we teach a bunch
of girls how to defend themselves they
are grateful to us adrenaline is Flowing
next thing you know Isabelle and
Brittany are kissing us on the mouse
you can be our club advisor you know my
mom did say I need to pick up a hobby
Club best
[Music]
[Applause]
I have a safe space like this it means a
lot to people I'm gonna finally reverse
stock my stalker yeah I'll be able to
kill my stepdad awesome
seems so supportive of women especially
the hot ones man-made therapy
are you cheating on me no I literally
saw you yesterday sub nerd I [__] your
mom
they are literally at the bottom you
have nowhere to open up
[Music]
your clock is over
they deserve a shot at showing everybody
how [__] cool they are
a place
you created a Fight Club to get some
coaching I don't even know how to work
thing I know y'all ain't tickling the
Pearl I just don't know if you're
supposed to be talking to us like that
just like as a teacher
foreign
[Music]
wow that was corny when I said it out
loud
never faced anything
like this
yeah
if you keep your eyes open plus we'll
show you everything you need to know
together
[Music]
Transformers rise of the Beast yeah turn
it up
on my soul
it's not the house that's haunted
haunted it's your son
[Music]
good
morning
[Applause]
our family has been through a lot
together
you told me when I was 10. it was in a
coma but I don't remember being sick
we're ready to forget
ever since then I see crazy stuff with
my dreams
[Music]
those are not dreams
happening again
something is following us
I'm gonna need you to remain still
hello
[Music]
the further you travel
the riskier the journey becomes
these guys put their lives online
every single day
we sleep good at night because these
guys deal with the ugly
[Music]
how are we gonna get out of here
Monday's for sure
you don't come out the same way you went
in
see how it states two suspects present
possession of God
you're looking at life for killing a cop
so we need your connects we got a tip
from a confidential informant about a
stash we get suspicious you didn't
notify him on the warrant
just one of those things
watch yourself
remember that money house I told you all
about
I'm gonna need your help
you get a million bucks do you hear what
you're asking me to do
this without you
it's an informing
yeah I don't think I could do this bro
you better do it
probably gonna explain this
you made me miss my Yankees game so what
do you got two Mel's game pass across
the victim's door they know exactly
where the money is they don't kill
anyone
you figure they were cops here
I've been having nightmares what if
somebody finds out
is Tommy taking money on the side
never
you got a dead cop a hero partner and a
widow this investigation is over my gut
is right on this song all you got is
conjecture
[Music]
about an inch away from getting bounced
out of the iaab inside jobs protect the
community uphold the law sometimes you
got to do a small wrong
for being right
because of your night you want to turn
right
my Mom leaves at nine
it's where'd you get it from anyway
apparently was the hand of someone who
could connect to the Dead
[Music]
I heard it was a hand of a site mess the
other hand's just out there
white people [__] man a day
[Applause]
you know the drill say talk to me
talk to me
Haley [__] stop it he's choking 83
seconds to get it off him
what if we open the door but we didn't
shut it
[Applause]
I'm not gonna stop
what was it
I let you in I let you in
oh my God
what's up
after all she's been through she's
trying to make up for what happened to
her you mean how West her brainwashed
her and made her come after us no one's
blaming Jill for that
no one
what's up Jill
Dr Taylor yes we need him in custody
ASAP I checked the DNA we got from a
bite wound on an orca carcass it had a
strain of t-virus in it you're kidding I
found the connection between the folks
that were infected they all visited
Alcatraz recently
well Dr Taylor
it's time we debuted our creation
they turn fast and without being bitten
I'm Rebecca what do you want me to tell
them someone accessed the dod server
they managed to steal data on Leon Jill
Chris and Claire you think this might
have something to do with the Opera now
most likely
I'm going to use my virus too clean the
Slate
Dylan suckers you're nothing more than
pause
that can't be good
yeah
[Music]
excuse me
it's all yours
we're at the final stage now that there
is no justice well it's over now
[Music]
time to light you up let's do it all of
us
definitely going on vacation after this
[Music]
something isn't right
I don't know what's going on
I need to find a way back yes
aware
what can you tell us about this wizard
you do his castle beyond that you're the
one's intent on dying right
she's an angel come to save us all
never seen anyone fight like that
you're a Wanderer
we have to kill them before they kill us
if the only way to stop their Invasion
cats you said you wanted to prove
yourself this is the time
evil is as Unstoppable as the rain fired
that's why we fight for those that can't
a good man knows that Darkness will
always be there and stands against it
anyway
[Music]
thank you
where on Earth are we not earth
War World
well welcome back to the New Jersey math
Olympics State final Candace youngster
win it all and it is Prince Mattel at
the buzzer do you believe in miracles
happy first day of seventh grade did you
have another math dream yep did you win
yep nice come on here comes the two to
the three and four I'm so excited this
year we have some 12 year olds joining
our high school class who's ready to get
marinated
I actually need some help with something
it's about Dad I miss him too pram I'll
never know who I am unless I know who he
was
your father had a real way with words
wait Dad was a rapper for real what's
his name probably haven't heard of him
he died when I was five
[Music]
hi
wait why are we yelling dad
Seth are you ghost a goat no I'm too old
for an imaginary friend well you're too
young for a midlife crisis but here we
are who is Ray Patel
that's on me I can't grab why not hip
hop is in your DNA
this methol thinks he's a rapper now
you couldn't school but in the real
world you'll always be a loser
hey truth is bullies are afraid of
dreamers
[Music]
you're not a rapper brame you love math
this matters to me this is inside you
[Music]
Riding in Cars with high schoolers
do they Vape no matter where we go just
do you do your best that's what's
important
[Music]
people
[Applause]
can I get two glasses of temper Ed
please
be bad luck to open a bottle of wine and
not finish it do you do this a lot do
what pick up sad and Confused women in
the farthest reaches a Little Haiti only
ones as gorgeous and interesting as you
[Music]
I've got a lot of things going on I just
want to get to know you I've been
getting these blackouts I'm left for
this really strange sense of deja vu
and you die over over you're safe
you're here with me
it feels like I'm not seeing all of you
you know everything about me do I
[Music]
we're definitely seeing an acceleration
of memory loss I just think I can really
help you through this transition
sweetheart what if I could give you the
perfect life that you always wanted
wouldn't you want that I need some time
to think I just hope you figure it out
before it's too late
she'll do anything to keep you from
blackouts
headaches
and getting worse right
I feel like I'm losing my mind
why would you do it
because we're meant to be together
[Music]
next time
foreign
headaches and maybe some form of
hallucination
[Music]
everything is going to be okay trust me
where's mom she's not feeling very well
what's going on
[Music]
I want you to visualize what it is
that's troubling you and then I want you
to laugh openly at it
you have no idea what I'm doing to fix
what you have done
[Music]
laughs
you're home now and oh we couldn't be
happier
ladies what's the name the Americas
first prize two tickets to lures best of
luck he's so fun
do it for anyway I always wanted to go
there if you go to the doctor don't
please bother coming back miracles
happen there he could speak how are you
Chrissy my mother is dead I'm in a place
I swore I would never come back to I I
wouldn't have recognized you 40 years
I'd say yep mixed yes great to have her
back marvelous not even marvelous
congratulations you're coming to Lourdes
who's gonna have to do the cooking in
the cleaning not me I can tell you
that's your job what did I do on my own
I'll be back before you know it you're
weird
[Music]
okay Mary [__]
welcome to Lourdes here's I am sharing
with you is there only one bed yeah I
wouldn't trust I am not my mother I
ain't got the truth
[Music]
[Applause]
why did you leave leave I was banished
Eileen
I loved you and you left uncle had you
came home can you ever
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
no stations the trail gentlemen what can
Arch do for you conspiracy this is a
threat against our very Foundation we
must protect our Collective from this
clear combination negotiation I shall
take it from here skedaddling you're
gonna have to run away what
you can't possibly think I did this
we've been waiting all day for this
haven't you
that could have been a baby's head now
do you get it
oh my God
[Music]
look Margaret
an invisible man plagues the town of
iping what Truss
clearly the vocal viping have lost the
ability to hear the words coming out of
their own mouths
eventually yes I'd be deceiving you
this
is a Manhunt
have you experienced any suspicious
occurrences
strange noises
Broken Window
no no
nothing like that
I can do many things while invisible
wildlife
things that ordinary men cannot
she's in League with him
Oscar it's written all over a lying face
what part did you play this
it's crazy it's dangerous
this time you chose to slide
yourself
[Music]
it's blood on your hands
thank you
[Music]